做的兄弟姐妹啊，
但凡你是年幼的时候被抛弃了，
被送人的啊，
你一定要占领这个道德制高点，
这个道德制高点就是现在，
我想怎么对待你们，
全凭我的心情，
全凭什么事儿对我有利，
我就怎么对待你们，
如果你们有几套房我可以继承，
那我可以认回来呀，
都给我听好了啊。
时时务者为俊杰，
不要跟钱过不去啊，
可能是33岁，
原生家庭呢，
是四个月的时候好像就把你送走了，
养父养母呢，
对你一直都是不错的，
后来呢，
养父去世了，
养母和哥哥嫂嫂坚持送你读书，
就是让你能够读出来，
然后你20岁的时候闪婚是吧，
我是20岁闪婚，
前面一段婚姻是有一双儿女，
分手是因为挣不了钱，
自由戏引他往里面充钱，
也不挣钱，
也不干活，
法院判的是无抚养费，
然后孩子有爷爷奶奶在，
他们比较年轻，
但是我中间也带了我的孩子，
嗯，
但是修改周围人说孩子也不要我干什么的，
19年年末的时候，
我因我现在的男友就是现任，
就是二婚嘛，
然后我们就换了一个地方，
在湖北的地方开了一个茶餐厅，
啊，
我投了10万，
他父母资助了10万，
我又刷了十几万的信用卡，
在一年的时候我们去登记结婚了，
又有一个女儿，
也是正常经营的，
我们也把所有的债都还。
还完了，
我是有一个商品房，
有一辆10万的车，
在我没有跟我二婚丈夫登记结婚之前，
我借了我娘家，
我哥哥嫂嫂有八九万块钱，
因为他们那时候要开钢材店，
需要用钱，
然后我就借给他们了，
这是属于我二婚之前的财产，
我跟我嫂子说这个属于我婚前财产，
现在老公也知道我有借娘家那个钱，
我没办法要回来，
我一要他们可能就是以这种借口，
说是我们还没有分婚前财产，
我要的时候他可能会跟我的养我就是我的妈妈他们闹别扭嘛，
就是我是为了我的妈妈，
我老公给我出的主意说是，
那就先不要吧，
因为我现在我哥哥嫂子他们还有一个上高中的，
上大学的女儿，
工资嘛，
我也不知道怎么要这个钱，
现在你大概一年能挣多少钱？
我们孩子给爷爷奶奶很会帮我们的，
带着孩子跟我老公自己干一年，
可能就是自己万嘛，
我是这么看待这个问题的啊，
因为当我的养父死的时候，
我的养母和我的哥哥嫂嫂坚持送我读书，
他们也是付出了成本的，
他们也是有着很大的压力跟我读书，
让我读了一些书出来的话，
至少待人接物，
文化上谈吐上有了一定的提升，
有了一定的基础，
我也有了今天这种挣钱的本事。
所以这个事情的话，
如果说我自己。
日子越过越好，
我现在也没有饥荒，
也没有任何的这样一个太大的这种经济的窟窿的话，
那这个事情就是看开一点，
当是我还了你们当年顶着压力送我去读书的这个人情债了，
如果他们有一天还给我，
当然我收着，
如果他们不还我，
我就不惦记了。
我知道我讲这个话，
可能直播间有很多姐妹都会觉得，
龙飞姐，
你现在是不是太有钱了，
站着说话不腰疼，
我是告诉你，
因为第一你要也要不回来，
第二的话，
你就得自己安慰自己，
你得自己会给自己的思想找个出口，
不然的话你就钻牛角尖了，
你钻牛角尖了之后，
人就容易睡不着觉啊，
老想这事儿啊，
老过不去这坎儿啊，
对自己的身体又不好，
所以基于这几点，
第一要反正也要不回来，
第二我不能老想这事儿，
老钻牛角尖呀，
就这意思，
他有说是愿意，
不是说不愿意给我他婆说的意思说是没有分清楚这个婚前财产跟我现任意思，
如果给我的话，
就会共同意婚后财产。
他为什么我这么着急，
这么焦虑，
是因为我不是有钱跟儿女他们现在大了嘛，
爷爷奶奶也是挣钱的能力下降了，
他跟我说有点困难，
所以我就开始焦虑，
现任为什么不同意给我前面的我的钱，
就是因为法院判的无抚养费啊。
还有就是我前夫她有游戏营，
他会把钱充到游戏里面，
就是她如果正经的这个钱的话，
前面的那个婆婆她也正经，
他是完全可以覆盖两个的。
我正常的生活需要，
他没有好好挣钱，
然后我婆婆的年龄越来越大了，
她挣钱能力下降了，
我这个新人她就是说的意思，
我平常给他们买日用品，
买生活用品啊，
然后给她买吃的喝的什么都可以，
但是给钱的话，
我感觉就是作为一个现任，
不应该对妻子的婚前的这些债务问题有那么强的干预欲望，
没有说干预他，
不干预他，
其实人挺好的，
给孩子耐心，
然后对我也挺好。
你想要问我的问题是什么，
我前婚这个儿女，
然后他不是要上学，
就一个上初中，
一个上小学，
现在需要更多的钱了，
我想要我这个原生家庭的那个钱，
就是应该跟他签一个什么婚前财产协议啊，
这个房子他就没有那个顾虑，
然后他就可以把这个钱，
然后我就可以用到的钱，
那其实不需要我跟你讲，
因为你们之间确实是实实在在的借款关系，
只要你的哥哥嫂嫂，
比如说举个例子啊，
直接还现金给你，
是不是一点都不影响，
这是一方面，
另一方面，
你新办一张卡，
跟你现在的所有的卡都不搭嘎，
就用来收哥哥嫂嫂还的这一笔8万块钱，
这也是能证明是你个人的，
也跟你老公不搭嘎的，
并不需要说一定要签一个什么协议才行，
你哥哥嫂嫂那纯属是借口，
他不是说担心你和你老公现在的财产混同了，
他就是暂时不想还，
就想拖着，
因为有太多方法可以解决这个问题了，
但他说的意思是。
介意我签一个婚前财产，
这样姐妹啊，
如果你想干成这事儿的话，
这事儿好办，
他不是建议我签一个婚前协议吗？
我就婚前协议是我跟谁签的，
谁能知道呢？
我就跟我哥哥嫂婆说，
我跟我老公签了婚前协议了，
这样这下你们放心了，
就是我跟我老公没钱，
我自己签的不行吗？
如果说真想要回来这个钱，
而你哥哥嫂嫂真如你所言是为了关心你的话，
咱好解决，
你就去单独开一张新卡，
让他们打到你的卡里，
你就说我跟我老公已经签了协议了，
来给你们看一下，
其实我觉得什么时候要都行，
或者就是给他，
然后让他们那个经济压力宽松一点，
让我母亲生活好一点，
我是更愿意轻向的给的，
那现在情况变了，
就成婚的儿女，
他们是需要钱，
然后前夫又不挣然，
所以我是更倾向于要回来的，
那你就按我这个方法去要啊，
第一重新办一张新卡，
第二转账呢，
是由你的哥哥或嫂嫂直接转到你卡里，
并且备注还款。
还有一个问题是我在我二婚之前，
然后他想认我，
你亲生的妈妈现在想要认你，
这个你亲生的妈妈有退休工资吗？
没有吧，
有攒钱吗？
具体的我我不太情况啊，
你去观察一下，
如果你亲生的妈妈比如说有几栋房在那儿有遗产，
比如说有退休金能帮衬我，
我可以让啊，
识时务者为俊杰，
当年你抛弃了我，
是不是现在你为了弥补一下你良心上的这个债，
你想要对我好，
我可以啊，
我可以接纳好。
处啊，
如果你的亲生的妈妈现在是属于那种又没有退休工资，
又没有生活保障，
现在想来占你就纯属现在想来占你的便宜，
那我就可以不认。
他的意思是不要让我心里负担，
就是想空同受伤手指多少，
人家给他6万块钱，
他想把这6万块钱以他自己残疾的6万块钱给我补偿，
我说是要帮我，
但是我说我考虑我养母的感受，
如果我养母同意的话，
我就认，
如果我养母不同意，
我以我养我的感受为先，
这玩意儿不划算，
他6万块钱是以小博大，
你今天拿了这6万块钱以后你要是不养他，
你就不对，
不对，
我养你的意思就是一方面就是他觉得感情上害怕，
我认了。
当时我就跟他说，
我说你感情上你完全可以放弃，
那就不认了，
这6万块钱我感觉就是以小博大，
你要敢收了这6万块钱的话，
他以后没准就缠着你，
对对对，
然后说因为家庭那边是有一个姐姐，
有一个哥哥，
然后姐姐远嫁了，
可能他没有女儿了，
他就突然就想起了我，
可能就是这种情况吧，
尊重你和你养母的共同的决定啊，
不认就不认了啊，
这个事情这样做应该是自己的是吧？
对，
没有任何毛病，
所有的兄弟姐妹啊，
但凡你是年幼的时候被抛弃了，
被送人的啊，
你一定要占领这个道德制高点，
这个道德制高点都是现在，
我想怎么对待你们，
全凭我的心情，
全凭什么事对我有利，
我就怎么对待你们，
如果你们有几套房。
我可以继承，
那我可以认回来呀，
都给我听好了啊，
识时务整，
于俊杰不要跟钱过不去啊，
如果说你们现在老了，
病了残了，
因为我突然想起来有个送出去的儿子，
送出去的闺女了，
那不好意思了，
咱俩没有这个法律关系了，
就我现丈夫的公婆，
他是重男轻女，
我现在生的是一个女儿，
其实跟我老公商量好了，
我们是不再生了，
但是跟她父母可能就是闹的面和心不平，
那这种场景，
因为跟他们又必须要接触的，
结合在一起，
可能我的能量就是被拉低了，
因为我心里可能是有一点难受，
就是说你和你老公达成共识了，
这是你们两口子的事儿，
别人要想甩脸色，
别人要想干嘛的话，
他也不可能逼着你生孩色，
也不可能逼着你怀孕，
是不是我觉得这事儿的话，
就是心里面觉得我没有说对不起谁，
生不生孩子是我跟我老公俩人的事儿，
根本们谁也没关系，
我没有对不起谁，
我也不需要看谁的脸色，
性格合咱俩就多说两句话，
性格不合的话，
各吃各的饭，
各做各的饭，
就是在这个二婚结婚之前，
我不是存了一部分财产，
没有让我送给老公，
知道我现在就是我怎么把这个钱，
就是让我钱婚子女用到，
如果没用的话，
到时候他们就是说说我用婚内财产怎么怎么，
如果你的这笔钱是在你婚前就单独存到一张卡里的，
这个在婚后呢，
没有跟你的。
给他存款混在一锅粥里，
那么这个存款在法律上呢，
是你的婚前个人存款，
你的婚前个人存款，
比如说你是想用到你婚前的那两个儿女身上，
就算是你想拿来做美容，
做整容，
做什么植发什么的，
都是你的自由，
哪怕你用来捐了都是你的自由，
因为你没有损害婚后的另外一方的共同利益，
这是你的婚前存款，
你自己完全可以说了算，
你捐了都行，
嗯，
啊，
在法律上都没毛病，
针对我这种油荣寡断的性格啊，
能量比较低的这种人，
我想让你给我一些衷心的建意，
衷心的建议多看龙飞的视频，
多看龙飞的分析，
跟着龙飞的思路，
做那个杀伐决断的，
敢于为自己的决定去买单，
去负责任的这样一个动作，
你每天按照这个动作去做，
慢慢慢慢也就形成了这样的性格，
非常坦率的说，
从我本人的喜好来说的话，
我不喜欢跟优柔寡断的人打交道，
我的身边没有优柔寡断的朋友，
没有优柔寡断的闺蜜，
没有优柔寡断的亲戚，
但凡我身边有一个这种左也不是，
右也不是啊，
优柔寡断的人的话，
我都会跟她断了联系，
所以什么意思呢？
啊，
姐妹们啊，
你们千万不要成为那个招人嫌的人，
千万不要成为那个左也不是，
右也不就怎么都过不幸福，
怎么都过不快乐的人，
到最后的话，
就算是亲生的子女也会逃离你们的，
所以我希望你们。
早意识到这个问题，
不要做那样的人，
不要做亲生的儿女都讨厌，
都想逃离的人，
要做一个就是杀伐决断，
我选了就是最好的，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
就是我直播间有很多女孩子，
她就是这种优柔寡断的性格，
左也不是，
右也不是，
选了这个也不幸福，
选了那个也不快乐，
想这么做啊，
又又觉得前怕狼，
想这么做又觉得后怕虎。
龙飞姐，
我就跟你们讲啊，
尽早发现自己有这样的状态，
尽早的去改掉自己这个状态，
让自己把以前的自己杀死，
把以前那个优柔寡断的自己杀死掉，
亲手杀死他，
然后塑造一个杀伐决断的利利落落的这样一个人，
不然的话，
真的连儿女都会逃离你的，
记得点赞关注哦。